When checking blood glucose levels, is this random or between meals or fasting?
I'll go back to the member site and the homepage of the member site.
It states, a fasting, mortied, reading of one's glucose levels can be a great indication that a cancer is not being fed through goblin up sugar.
To keep your glucose levels down, everybody's cancer is going to have, is going to be fed by glucose to some degree.
Why? Because every cell uses glycolysis in order to make ATP.
So ATP is your main energy source for every cell function, not so function in everything else.
So keeping your blood glucose levels as low as possible is a benefit to everybody with cancer.
And like I said before, even if you don't have cancer.
So we want to set a goal to get our fasting, like a 10 or 12 hour fast fasting goal of blood glucose out of 70 fiber last.
That's a pretty handsome goal. Most of you won't be able to accomplish that goal.
But that's a goal. I mean, you have to have a goal that's hard to match or it's not really a goal.
So it's best measure by taking your mortied, first mortied reading, when you wake up before you eat anything or drink anything with a glucometer such as this.
You could buy them at Target or Walmart or something like that. This is one that's on Amazon.
And I gave the link here. I was about 100 of these test strips.
So take your fasting, mortied reading and recorded on this chart. You can download that chart on the member site.
You can do it daily. Your figure starts to get sore and your blood sugar is kind of stayed at a same level every day that you could.
So wait, take it every three days or whatever down the weekly and your goal is to get it down, you know, as though it's reasonable.